[Musique]
on va parler maintenant idées avec
pierre henri tavoillot bonjour
vous êtes vous êtes philosophe vous
enseignez à la sorbonne à sciences po
votre dernier livre dont nous avions
d'ailleurs parlé ici s'appelle la morale
de cette histoire c'est paru chez chez
michel lafon et puis vous présidez le
collège de philosophie de la sorbonne et
c'est d'ailleurs dans ce collège de
philosophie qui a eu lieu le vendredi et
samedi deux premiers vendredis samedis
de janvier un colloque sur le thème
après la déconstruction
reconstruire les sciences et la culture
alors pour être très clair je reprends
la phrase de présentation de ce colloque
sur le site du collège de philosophie la
posséder coloniale aussi nommé au bouc
ou quand cette culture représente un
défi pour le monde éducatif alors avant
d'essayer de comprendre ce défi il faut
qu'on essaie de définir ses mots qu'est
ce que c'est la posséder coignières le
nialé qu'est ce que c'est lebouc
alors d'abord c'est un certain nombre de
phénomènes que l'on voit pas seulement
d'ailleurs dans le monde universitaire
mais qui sont très présents dans le
monde universitaire ces phénomènes qu'on
voit notamment qu'on perçoit que des
statues sont déboulonnés
quand on entend l'idée qu'il faudrait
des genres et des cours de récréation
pour faire en sorte que voilà les
discrimination entre les sexes existent
donc il ya toute une série de phénomènes
dans la société
dont on peut dire qu'ils nous viennent
pour une large part des états unis mais
on voit aussi émerger en france qui
témoignent du fait qu'il ya une sorte de
pression voire de moralisation sur un
certain nombre de comportements et puis
dans le monde académique on identifie
aussi un certain nombre de cas par
exemple des conférences qui sont
perturbés voire parfois interdite parce
que précisément ils ne représenteraient
pas sur un certain nombre de thèmes
notamment les questions de deux rapports
sur la race qui revient d'ailleurs la
formule est d'ailleurs intéressante par
rapport au genre par rapport à
à éventuellement d'ailleurs aussi des
questions d'écologie radical qui
viennent et qui constitue une sorte de
pression et de moralisation des débats
avec des choses qu'on peut dire et puis
des choses qu'on n'a pas le plus droit
ou pas le droit de dire ou pas le droit
d'ailleurs de discuter donc ça c'est le
contexte social c'est ça non il ya aussi
un moment intellectuelle alors après
tout s'inquiétait des inégalités des
d'égalité qui qui qui perdu c'est tout à
fait légitime ce qui vous préoccupe
moins sur le type c'est que au nom de
cette lutte contre contre les égalités
on introduit une une sorte d'ordre moral
1 je vous cite incompatible avec nos
principes
d'universalisme et de laïcité c'est ça
qui vous inquiète oui c'est ça c'est à
dire en fait nous pouvons être prendre
un tout petit peu de recul le pour ça
qu'on a appelé ce colloque après la
déconstruction parce que la
déconstruction est un mouvement
intellectuel qui est d'ailleurs très
puissant et très profond on peut
identifier
en fait trois âges de la déconstruction
pour bien apprendre bien donné le
contexte avoir il ya de pertinent est ce
qu'il nous semble de plus dit parce que
la déconstruction ça fait partie de
l'histoire des idées et de la
philosophie oui on peut le dire même que
c'est toute la philosophie moderne
jaillir des cartes quand il pratique son
doute radical
dont la situation est très simple dit
voilà j'ai appris beaucoup de choses en
matière de théologie puis je suis un peu
perdue donc je vais pratiquer ce qu'il
appelle le doute c'est à dire l'idée que
je vais douter de tout donc c'est une
forme de déconstruction jusqu'à ce que
je trouve quelque chose de certain sur
laquelle je puisse reconstruire
l'édifice des sciences et cette petite
chose certaine bas tout le monde la
connaît ça fait partie de la culture de
base c'est je doute de quoi puis-je de
ne pas douter c'est du fait que je doute
si je doute je pense et si je pense je
vais bien je vois la fameux cogito et
bien sûr ce cogito il reconstruit
ensuite l'édifice des sciences pour
qu'on voit ici une premiers âges de la
déconstruction qui est un âge où on
déconstruit pour construire et rapport à
des choses qui nous paraissent infondées
crd notamment les dogmes théologique
c'est à dire les vérités révéler des
vérités qui ne sont pas produites par
les hommes ça c'est le premier âge de la
déconstruction il ya un deuxième âge
qui commence avec schopenhauer et avec
nietzsche lui aussi très intéressant et
très puissant dans l'histoire de la
pensée qui consiste à faire à appliquer
cette méthode de la déconstruction cette
méthode de l'esprit critique sur les
vérités humaine elle-même c'est-à-dire
sur le vrai humain sur le beau sur la
science sur la morale nietzsche définit
sa manière de philosopher comme
philosopher avec le marteau déconstruire
les idoles ce qu'on croit en fait on une
histoire n'y a pas d'absolu dans la
personne humaine pourquoi était-il ça il
fait ça parce qu'il considère que ces
idées nous empêche de vivre pleinement
sa c'est là l'argument de nietzsche il
est repris par freud qui consiste à dire
que pour lui ces idées humaine nous
empêche masque en quelque sorte des
conflits psychiques elle est reprise
aussi par marx à certains égards qui
consiste à dire que toutes ces idées
même les droits de l'homme les choses
comme ça nous empêche de voir les
conflits entre les classes les luttes
des classes il reprit aussi par
heidegger qui consiste à dire que toutes
ces idées cette rationalité nous empêche
de percevoir au fond la vérité de l'être
ce qu'ils appellent pour heidegger
l'être lui-même donc il faut
déconstruire ça c'est pour dire l'esprit
critique c'est absolument nécessaire
mais à chaque pour arriver à quelque
chose qui reconstruit
simplement après il ya un troisième âge
voilà ce troisième âge on peut le faire
débuter avec ce qu'on appelle la pensée
68 c'est à dire dépenses françaises
derrida foucault bourdieu qui eux pour
une par produit ça mais avec l'idée
qu'il faut déconstruire pour se
déconstruire déconstruire pour
déconstruire et ça ça arrive en effet à
ce qu'on peut appeler la pensée ou au
cas où la pensée je vais essayer de
définir la pensée déconstructionniste
intersectionnelle assez des mots clés
m'entends beaucoup alors je veux qu'on
peut la qualifier définir ce cette idée
en cinq ans quatre grandes idées pour
aller vite l'idée 1 toute la société
c'est un rapport de domination les
hommes ce qui c'est vrai que domination
les relations hommes-femmes au fond
c'est la domination des hommes sur les
femmes les relation à la nature c'est la
domination du productivisme et du
capitaliste sur la nature les relations
entre les races c'est la domination de
la race blanche sur les autres roja ce
même si le terme de race et on le sait
problématique du conduite biologique
donc au fond on a des lunettes qui nous
permettent de regarder le réel
uniquement à partir de l'idée de
domination tout et domination et ce qui
n'est pas domination n'existe pas ça
c'est la première idée à partir de là le
comble de la domination pour cette
pensée justement et colonial c'est le
colonialisme occidental
c'est pour ça que c'est une pensée très
anti occidental il faut la colonisation
c'est le comble de la domination
humaines de l'homme sur la femme du nord
sur le sud de la technique sur la nature
etc donc c'est au complot troisième idée
pardon je vais un peu vite mais
la décolonisation
l'émancipation de la femme la
préoccupation de l'environnement sur
l'environnement tout ça ce sont des
illusions c'est de la poudre aux yeux en
fait la domination est toujours là et
peut-être beaucoup plus sournoise et
puissante qu'elle n'a jamais été par le
passé donc en apparence les femmes sont
libres en vérité le patriarcat est
toujours là c'est ça l'idée c'est parce
que je défends c'est de résumer environ
crois qu'on est voilà écolo parce qu'on
fait du tri etc n'a pas du tout la
nature est en train de mourir sous le
capot les coûts du capitalisme et donc à
partir de là oui le sentiment que la
domination est encore plus puissante
aujourd'hui et à cause de l'occident
qu'elle n'a jamais été alors on gomme la
tue tout ce qu'il a pu exister par le
passé c'est le fait que les
civilisations occidentales est pas la
seule à économiser avoir colonisé
qu'elle avait été la seule eau dans
toute l'histoire de l'humanité avoir
aboli l esclavage la seule
et puis à partir de là je termine mon
raisonnement
face à cette ampleur de la domination et
là c'est tout à fait logique et bien qui
a une seule chose à faire d'abord il
faut se réveiller et walk haute et là il
s'est réveillé cette domination n'est
pas aussi palpable qu'on puisse le pot
qu'on peut le penser mais ça suffit pas
tu réveillé il faut annuler cancel
culture il faut impérativement agir y
compris quand on est un universitaire
nous voit le passage de la théorie à la
pratique il faut supprimer il faut
abolir les stéréotypes il faut lutter
contre tous et domination sournoise que
l'on ne voit pas et qui sont évidemment
absolument abjecte d'où le fait qu'on a
affaire là souvent par en général mais
pour ceux qui sont pratiquants de cette
logique à des universitaires qui sont
devenus des militants qui sont devenus
des personnes qui veulent passer de la
théorie à la pratique et qui sont
parfois prêts à tout pour y parvenir
c'est ça c'est ce que vous dites c'est
que cette ce jeu enfin deux entre la
domination et l'oppression ne suffit pas
à constituer une grille de lecture
suffisante mais alors les l'ailé donnant
enfin au fond de ces théories vous
répondre en disant que ba rendre
visibles les facteurs
d'inégalités de discrimination c'est pas
être idéologue
sa saison pas tout à fait
c'est le point est absolument essentiel
simuler le point de clivage entre disons
les positions que je peux défendre et
puis les milices l'europe n'est pas
capable domination s'est pas de dire qu'
il n'y a pas de choses scandaleuses dans
le monde qui a pas de discrimination
c'est l'idée de dire qu'il n'ya pas que
des disques in m6 avec des
discriminations à mon avis on ne
pourrait pas lutter contre c'est de dire
que nous avons des principes notamment
les principes démocratiques issues des
droits de l'homme européen
inventé par les par l'europe qui sont
des principes de justement
d'émancipation et que c'est pas en
détruisant ses principes démenti les
passions qu'on va faire avancer les
choses mais c'est en s'appuyant sur ces
principes pour faire progresser la lutte
contre la discrimination à vous faire
avancer la démonstration des femmes
faire avancer la tension à la protection
de l'environnement c'est justement le
fait que de dire tout n'est pas
domination par exemple dans les rapports
hommes femmes il ya un truc qui
s'appelle l'amour et qui n'est pas de
l'or ou simplement de la domination de
l'homme sur la femme dans les rapports
sociaux il ya l'amitié dont le rapport
au passé il ya des liens qu'ont de
comprendre ça s'appelle l'histoire
l'histoire rigoureuse et c'est pas en
déboulonnant la statue de colbert on va
faire avancer la cause de la de la
condition des noirs dans l'histoire
c'est passe pas comme ça c'est au
contraire en comprenant ce qui s'est
passé par le passé en évitant toute
espèce de révisionnisme alors osez vous
l'avez dit c'est ce genre d'aidé des
bons c'est qu'ils nous viennent des
états unis les ya peut-être d'ailleurs
un petit effet boomerang parce que vous
parliez de derrida de foucauld qui ont
été beaucoup étudié aux états unis qui
nous reviennent à un petit peu comme ça
en pleine face mais au fond alors c'est
très bien de faire des colloques comme
ça mais on a quand même l'impression que
la france et l'université peut être
aussi française justement grâce au
principe d'universalisme kiki qui nous
qui nous fonde résiste assez bien quand
même assez mouvement est ce qu est ce qu
il y aurait eu ça c'est où est-ce qu'il
faut être inquiet justement
ça c'est une culture de vraiment
d'évaluation de la situation moi je
respecte tout à fait les gens qui nous
disent qu au fond c'est pas très très
grave que l'on a les ressources pour
lutter contre ça c'est pas la peine d'en
faire un plat je suis plus suspicieux à
l'égard de ceux qui nous disent son
arraisonnement extrêmement intéressant
qui nous disent 1 le walkie ça n'existe
pas
2 ça a toujours existé et 3 c'est
formidable donc voilà le raisonnement
qu'on nous avance qu'on nous oppose
après c'est une question d'évaluation de
la situation c'est vrai que là dessus il
faut être clair ce colloque avait
vocation à faire un état des lieux
essayer de voir si c'était effectivement
on essaie d'abord si on pouvait définir
la déconstructionniste pense qu'on y est
arrivé
à l'issue de ce colloque 2,6 était
potentiellement dangereux
je pense qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
témoignages dans des disciplines parce
que mon universitaire c'est beaucoup de
disciplines différentes et donc
difficile d'avoir une vision d'ensemble
donc là nous avions des gens des
sciences dures des gens donc d'émettre
titien des physiciens des gens de
musicologie des ans d'histoire de l'art
des gens de littérature jean de
philosophie et sociologie et donc voilà
on avait toute une série de témoignages
de personnes qui ont rapporté des faits
très très précis
indiquant qu on pouvait quand même d'un
peut s'inquiéter de la situation c'est à
dire que la montée en puissance de cette
idéologie constitue une pression qui
peut potentiellement mettre en péril la
liberté académique
et qui constituent une pression de plus
en plus importante même s'il faut
surtout pas en effet trop trop
dramatiser la situation et que nous
avons les ressources pour en france un
peu résisté c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
ce colloque a eu lieu probablement en
france et pas dans d'autres pays je juge
ainsi néanmoins sur le fait que ce
colloque en l'organisant en dehors d'un
contexte universitaire c'est juste c'est
pas mon université qui a organisé ce
colloque je n'aurais pas pu le faire
dans mon université les pressions ont
été très fortes le dès lors que locke
est apparu on a eu quand même ses titres
de noblesse des communiqués des
syndicats cgt sud unef pour dire que ce
colloque était scandaleux qui n'avait
pas de légitimité à se tenir donc voilà
c'est quand même un indice du fait que
ce genre de choses et ce genre de débat
on ne peut pas forcément les avoir
facilement et nous prenons des risques
nous avons eu des intervenants d'autres
colloques qui ont dit écoutez votre
colloque est formidable mais moi je suis
en phase de recrutement à l'université
si je participe à un colloque je suis
mort il aurait paru il ya d'ailleurs eu
des manifestations déduire on a entendu
le mot de phase i stem devenir très
intéressant d'ailleurs parce que il y
avait parmi les participants beaucoup de
gens et de et de gauche et de droite des
républicains quoi il ya peut-être il n'a
peut-être un je ne sais pas qui a
peut-être attirer ces reproches c'est
vous aviez
appelé dans ce colloque c'est mathieu
bloc copé
est ce que oui c est ce que qu'ils
apprennent quand même des positions
qu'il faut beaucoup zemmour et c est ce
que est ce que c'était une bonne figure
north colonnes de le prendre
c'est un universitaire d'abord il vient
du canada et du québec qui est un lieu
particulièrement important donc un
accord en avant-garde sur ces questions
s'est pas inintéressant de le faire bien
mais vous avez raison d'indiquer que
nous avions une diversité à la fois
disciplinaire et politique total e g
julien tu venir parce qu'il était mais
il va écrire un texte dans les actes du
colloque pour lui vraiment je veux pas
me parler à sa place mais j'ai eu une
conversation avec lui au téléphone pour
lui ce que l'autre présente ça ça m'a
beaucoup ému dans ce sens là un acte
refondateurs de la gauche voyez donc de
dire que ce sont des fascistes et des
conservateurs ou des réactionnaires qui
ont noué le colloque saignée que si l'on
à 50 50 il y avait des représentants de
la droite dé toutes les droites et des
représentants de je dirais pas toutes
les gauches parce que l'effet tina
embauches en ville à la gauche extrême
n'était pas présente mais je l'avais
milliken laïque enfin voilà qui était
qui étaient étaient de très grands avec
des personnalités des pointures sur le
plan académique j'ajoute par ailleurs
que ce colloque dont les enregistrements
sont disponibles pour chacun dans sa
sphère vie a été vraiment d'un très très
haut niveau passionnant chacun
souhaitant donner le meilleur et avec
des exemples nous intéressant je pense
notamment à l'intervention d' alexandre
gady
l'histoire de l'art et notamment une
statue de champ politique avait été
critiqué au collège de france dont il ya
eu des moments extrêmement forts
extrêmement puissants dans ce colloque
et j'invite évidemment tous ceux qui
s'intéressent à ce sujet de d'aller voir
par eux-mêmes tout simplement alors il
ya pour conclure il ya cette
déconstruction donc vous avez parlé à
traverser ces mouvements de pensée mais
il y avait dans le thème du colloque la
reconstruction alors la reconstruction
ça pourrait être quoi alors bon là c'est
un position personnelle parce que je ne
peux pas me faire le représentant ici de
tout le monde mais ses murs la
reconstruction au moins est justement de
dire qu' il y a dans les relations
sociales aujourd'hui des éléments de
destruction on a fait de domination et
des éléments de recomposition et c'est
ça qui m'intéresse pas personnellement
c'est de voir comment dans un univers
réputé individualiste où on nous
devrions tous être enfermés dans notre
sphère privée sans lien les uns avec les
autres le suspicieux ou indifférents les
uns avec les autres et bien notre
univers démocratique individualiste
produit du lien un indice
le monde démocratique les individus
d'aujourd'hui n'ont jamais été aussi
généreux il donne beaucoup d'argent
voilà générosité là d'un phénomène
impression ne devrait pas exister dans
notre monde individualiste et égoïste et
plus ça va mal d'ailleurs situation de
kobe de 19 où la france est dans une
situation problématique et bien au lieu
que ça baisse ça monte encore donc il ya
là des ressorts qui nous paraissent
extrêmement intéressant à étudier
pourquoi cet individu a besoin encore
envers et contre tous des autres pour
exister il a besoin de l'amour il a
besoin du lien social il a besoin du
rapport au passé par rapport critique il
a besoin de projets pour l'avenir ça
c'est de la reconstruction
merci infiniment je renvoie en effet au
site du collège de philosophie où on
peut écouter les débats que nous avons
eus vendredi et samedi de 7 et 8 janvier
merci beaucoup pierre henri tavoillot et
et bonne année une bonne année également
de la reconstruction
merci beaucoup